Peggy's 16
Italy World War two this proud nation
has suffered under years of fascistic
and growing influence from Nazi Germany
the Allied victory in North Africa has
stretched the axis held on the
Mediterranean to breaking point the time
to strike is now but the Allies need
more than a plan they need a specialist
an elite marksman who can sow chaos in
enemy ranks and hunt down the Nazi
weapon system that threatens not only
the invasion of Italy but victory in
Europe welcome to the most advanced
sniping game ever built a tactical
third-person shooter delivering emergent
free-flowing combat and genre Louisville
welcome to Sniper Elite 4 central to
Sniper Elite 4 is an expansive campaign
for one to two players across the
largest most diverse environments ever
seen in a world war 2 game from sleepy
fishing villages to mountainous valleys
ancient forests and more still untouched
by the bloody conflict that has ravaged
most of Europe each huge campaign level
is many times bigger than any previous
Sniper Elite game offering hours of pure
tactical combat gameplay freedom and
epic long shots traverse these vast
environments to find your ideal sniper
nest how to maneuver your enemies or
hunt them up close explore every inch
for hidden regions collectibles and
optional side missions that can be
completed in any order
deploy deep behind enemy lines you must
learn to observe the enemy and adapt to
the flow of battle with a combination of
your binoculars and Intel from Italian
resistance you can identify priority
targets track enemy movements plan
explosive ambushes and pick out more
creative opportunities use your athletic
prowess to scale vertical terrain with
ease get the drop on enemies for a range
of silent takedowns with any position or
find your own cyber nests to pick apart
the enemy at range offering a deep and
rewarding sniping simulation players can
deliver pinpoint assassinations from
extreme distance adapting to wind and
gravity and adjusting for range with
scope 0e for long shots over hundreds of
metres and when the hornet's nest has
been stirred cover your tracks with a
nasty surprise
keeping your enemy guessing is the key
to victory
silenced pistols can be combined with
distractions to torment enemy formations
luring them into traps and isolating
priority targets when engaging the enemy
at range
you can now load silent subsonic ammo
into your rifles delivering a much
quieter shot that's less likely to alert
nearby enemy forces
even without suppressed firearms expert
sharpshooters can mask their rifle fire
by timing shots with artillery and other
sounds of the battlefield
and make no mistake
sniper you'll want to tip the odds in
your favour with hundreds of fascist
troops armored vehicles and tanks in any
one environment every encounter will
provide a stern test special attention
must be paid to elite enemy units such
as the heavily armed Jaeger troops or
radio operators who can call in waves of
new enemy reinforcements to turn the
tide against you but the enemy's
strength can also be its weakness
assassinate an officer and you can
search his body for a logbook that
reveals the location of all his troops
and while the enemy spotters can use
their flare guns to call an artillery
strike on your positions that same
weapon can be used to rain down death on
Nazi defensive position
you might always be outnumbered but
you'll never be outgunned with weapons
and items to choose from including
iconic World War two rifles submachine
gun shot guns and explosives and heavy
weapons with decimating fearful patrols
agents can adapt their loadouts
for any mission players can also upgrade
their weapons core attributes from scope
magnification to stability recoil muzzle
velocity and more and no more crucial is
your arsenal than in Sniper Elite Force
wealth of online co-op and multiplayer
modes set across six beautiful
custom-designed Maps the dedicated co-op
loads for up to four players your team
play will be tested as a sniper and
spotter all pitted against ever
escalating enemy forces in a battle for
survival for competitive sharpshooters
seven adversarial modes bring sniper
elites trademark mechanics to the fall
ratcheting up the tension in a battle of
timing position and skill across
challenging terrain filled with hidden
sniping nests and deadly kill zone
it's time to deploy a sniper it's time
to liberate Italy and set the wheels in
motion for victory in Europe because one
bullet can change history
[Music]